you're a hilarious stand-up comedian and
the last time you were here doing
stand-up I noticed something take a look
at this picture you are a completely
different color shade of human yeah you
are a different color
last time than you are so what was the
story um well when I did stand up on
your show it was my debut doing stand-up
on television and I just got really
really nervous so instead of focusing on
my material and you know working on my
set I was like I'm just not the right
shade and so I put all of this focus on
to getting spray tans and I got one
spray tan and my now husband then
boyfriend was like okay that's enough
and then I was like no it's not no it's
not I have to go get another spray tan
and this is my big TV debut and so I
went and got a second spray tan yeah it
isn't double dipped and then I just
became like president-elect orange yes I
did notice that I remembered ever seeing
you backstage and thinking yes this is a
completely different UI
you look fine then you look much better
well thank you I'm no longer a Tahitian
leprechaun that's my green dress orange
scan the whole thing
you